les ukrainiens qu'on avait vu très
mesurée ces dernières semaines face aux
risques de conflit ils ont vécu une nuit
plutôt tourmenté et les heures qui
arrive s'annonce extrêmement difficile
pour beaucoup la guerre est en train de
se concrétiser reportage
dans les rues de pierre ce matin mais
une inquiétude palpable
les gens partent travailler comme un
jour normal mais le coeur serré
on a eu très peur on ne sait pas trop
quoi faire parce que moi j'ai des
enfants en bas âge je m'inquiète
vraiment
guerre ou pas guerre je ne sais pas mais
tout le monde a peur
on est sous le choc on ne sait pas quoi
faire comment réagir c'est juste fou ce
qui arrive chez le danger existe on ne
sait pas ce qu'il ya dans la tête de
poutine
dans le donbass hier soir une autre
ambiance ils suivent en direct le
discours de vladimir poutine et ils
laissent éclater leur joie
oui c'est encore un pas encore une
brique
a ajouté à cet édifice que l'on
construit depuis 2014
on est très heureux on a attendu depuis
huit ans c'est notre opposition à l'état
terroriste qui l'ukraine
le président russe a ordonné l'entrée de
ses troupes dans les enclaves
séparatistes leur étaient au feu
d'artifice une atmosphère du victoire
avec des séparatistes qui désespéraient
la peur